you seem to really imply when you first  sat down that this is gonna be the last  season for you of homeland this is what  because well you seem to say hey I've  done everything with this character I  get nervous I do not mean to say that in  in other words if they come to you and  say season six is gonna be happening  you're open to very very much so  oh okay no I well one I have to is that  how it works but even if it wasn't how  it works I would do it I really I love  these people so much that I've been  working with their it's and we've been  trying our best to make this as good as  we can for as long I want to see it to  the very end absolutely we love homeland  thank you  this is a great role for you I love what  you're doing with it I have no problem  with what you're doing I'm just so you  know no that's why you came in to hear  that